I'm gonna see how to be a game go Steve
Harvey debuting a new look this year you
know we launched a new season of soul
every now and then I reinvent myself you
know when I was 49 about to turn 50 I
would involved mm-hmm that was the thing
I always had a mustache you just didn't
know I had one because I had had two he
the same much - but then uh I started
last year was first time I had a summer
off yeah so I didn't shave I grew my
beard out but last year what enough
great in the mustache yeah so he looked
like I had stuff in it so I had to wait
another year this year when I didn't
color it it was a lot more gray so I'm
flipping this grill come with two
different suits and I'm gonna see how to
be a game go and that's just cuz a
vacation you're on vacation you said you
know I'm a grow animal keeper well you
know man when I'm on vacation I don't
have to wear makeup so I get seven weeks
of no makeup I get seven weeks waddle
had to put a raise on my face I say cool
this is vacation so I start growing it
last year I didn't let it get right
right I wasn't confident this year man
you know I just I said I'll just do
something different man I'm gonna stay
fly till I die Steve is putting his
latest face forward for this upcoming
season of Steve premiering September 4th
on NBC how are you balancing all the
stuff the family with you this the
little big shots all you have like good
like 99 shows well let's see I tell
everybody you know I get the same 24
hours did everybody else get God don't
give me no more hours if you maximize I
pack a minute man I care about every
minute of the day you'll be successful
if you get control of your time if you
take every minute of the day and monitor
every single minute of the day you be
stunned what you could accomplishment
you can get a lot done but you got to
cut the BS out your life you can't be at
the club every time it opened you can't
make all the happy hour
Ryan you can't watch scandal every night
that it come on the only program you
should watch every night that it come
home is family few programs should be
hard but you keep Harvey yeah yeah yeah
this is daytime any chance that you'll
change the logo if you if the beard
stays locked you know something man
somebody didn't already asked me that I
don't think we got to do nothing to it
I'm with Jess cuz you know look I might
keep it I might I don't know man
it's really up to the wife you see we
can take all the voting we won't
mm-hmm the woman you sleep with
determines what you do
[Music]
[Applause]